- You know what I'm saying?
I don't know how many times I did that.
I would call my family like,
"Fam, let me come home,
I'm a just change my whole life."
Soon as I get home, I'm back to ...
You feel me, 'cause
this game is addicting.
- [Interviewer] All right, Tasha.
- [Tasha] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Tasha,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- [Tasha] I'm from Compton, California.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about your family.
- Well,
my family, I grew up,
my mother,
she was on drugs and my
father was also on drugs but,
we, my grandmother raised me
along with my other siblings.
Two other siblings
and I grew up in Compton where,
I had- we grew up with my auntie,
my uncles were like all
close around the same age,
and I just remember like, you know
us being a cool family at first.
You know what I mean?
And things changed as
I got a little older.
- [Interviewer] What
kind of stuff changed?
- My attitude, the way
I am, the way I became.
You know, I started gang-banging first
and that led to prostitution,
which you know.
I mean, it hasn't changed since.
I started prostituting-
- [Interviewer] At what age?
- 16.
Started prostituting at age 16
and um,
my first encounter was,
I wanted to be a prostitute
cause I went to juvenile hall.
I was a very bad kid and ended
up going to juvenile hall.
When I was in juvenile hall,
I had a lot of time to do.
And I ended up meeting
a lot of young girls
being prostitutes.
So I wanted to try it because
they made it look so fun.
Like a lot of girls, 12, 13, 14, 15
all the way to, you know, 17,
you know, they talked about
how they made thousands,
you know what I'm saying?
And when they, when they
get caught, you know
they have paperwork, you know
they have reports when they get caught up.
So you reading that report
and you're like, "Oh,
this bitch 12 years old."
And she made a thousand
dollars off one night.
Oh, I'm, you know, I'm with that.
So when I got out, I never,
I said I wanted to do it.
I said, I told myself,
I said, "Oh, I'm gonna be a hoe."
I never- I told myself
that in juvenile hall.
And I never thought it happened so soon
but two weeks after I was
out of youth authorities
cause I ended up getting
sentenced to youth authorities.
I ended up running into a pimp.
And when I ran into a pimp,
I'm not going to say the name
but when I ran into him, he was so fine.
And so, so everything he
had to say was so right.
And so real because I was
looking for that love.
Like I was in touch with
my mother and my father,
you know what I'm saying?
And everything he said, "Oh
I'm going to take care of you.
I'm gonna do this. I'm gonna do that.
I'm gonna make sure you right."
You know and he did that when I,
you know what I'm saying?
First got with him, he did that for me.
He got my hair done, made me look like
you know what I'm saying?
I never knew I had, what
I had that much body.
I had a cute face, you
know what I'm saying?
I was just fresh out of YA.
You know what I'm saying?
Still kinda like boy-ish and
still kind of like a tomboy.
So when I met him, he put me in a dress
and I started seeing how
much attention I can get.
And you know, my first night
he asked me to do it for him.
My first night I made $500 in one hour.
So I'm like, "Oh, I'm pretty",
you know, "I'm this I'm that."
And I never looked back from there
and I have a lot of
respect in the streets.
Like so much respect
where I'm like a Renegade.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't have to have a pimp
I don't have to be scared on the streets
because a lot people pull up like,
"Oh you straight Spice?"
A lot of girls don't get that.
A lot of girls get harassment or jump out
and get beat up or you
know what I'm saying?
Not saying that no guys ever
tried me and beat me up.
Or you know, I've, I've gotten-
probably like second week in the game,
I got raped by, I guess
they call them the,
the rapist that they caught or whatever.
And he was taking all the
girls down to Figueroa.
I think I wanted to,
I don't know if I'm one of the first girls
or like in my area to get caught by him.
But he never, he hurt my
back and he hurt my neck
but he told me if I do everything right
he wasn't going to hurt me.
You know what I'm saying?
And he took my clothes, my shoes
he took my dress, my shoes.
He put me in a black T-shirt,
and dropped me off by
Rose plants and Central.
I'll never forget. He raped me though.
I told him I said, "I'm only 16."
He didn't care.
He just, and then he said
"If I ever see you out there again,
I'm going to get you" or whatever.
The next day, I'm not going to lie.
The next day, my pimp didn't care.
He still sent me back out there.
So the next day I see him,
he pulled up in his truck like this
and I started running.
And then I remember a Mexican girl
getting in the truck with him.
And I remember her coming back, cut up.
I've been through so much on
the streets of prostituting.
It's, it's really crazy.
And I've been prostituting since I was 16.
I'm 34 right now.
And I've never experienced doing crack.
I never experienced doing crystal.
You know, I never did cocaine.
What's up?
Ecstasy? Yeah. I'm not gonna lie.
That's my choice of drug.
It's Ecstasy.
Weed, I smoke that all day.
I don't care about,
but one thing I've been strong
in the streets where I'm 34 years old.
I look younger than half
these girls that come
and you know, do what they do.
But I been through a whole lot also.
And in this game, this game
is very, very, very crazy.
You know what I'm saying?
And I've been successful.
Like my brother, I brought
my brother to the game.
You know what I'm saying?
He ended up getting 40 years for this.
- [Interviewer] Is what? Is-
- A pimp
- [Interviewer] Is a pimp?
- Mhm. My brother, he was on the,
on the news
and from Compton where they said
that he was pimping
young girls and all that.
And then the guy I turned out,
it was three of them.
One of them, my cousin,
and one of them was the
guy turned out to the game.
You know what I mean?
He ended up getting some time too.
Like, I've been through a lot
in this game, but it's,
I mean, it's been fun.
I can't lie. You guys are fun.
Cause I'd been through
every state you can name,
you know what I mean?
And getting money.
- [Interviewer] So your
pimp would travel with you?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Or you go on your own?
- I've been on my own.
So, so many times it's crazy because
I do the Renegade thing a lot.
You know what I mean?
I don't- because my trust
issues are very high.
You know what I mean?
It's a lot of girls that get off here.
Cause I've been like recently I was
in a relationship where I
was getting beat and hit.
And you know what I'm saying?
I'm not saying getting
forced to go out there
cause I was going out there anyway.
But you know, he didn't
know if he wanted me to hoe
or if he wanted me to be a regular girl,
you know what I mean?
And it just got crazy from there.
You know what I mean?
And I have to- I've been,
I ran away from him,
I've been away from him for like a month.
You know what I mean?
I had to get away
because I've started
seeing scratches on me
and bruises on me that I,
I shouldn't even have on me.
You know what I mean?
Broken rib. You know what I mean?
Because he wanted to go,
he don't know if he want
to be with his baby mama,
me, you know what I mean?
He don't want me,
he don't know if he want me to hoe,
don't hoe, you know what I mean?
But,
I'm strung out here.
So, you know what I mean?
I've been shot and everything.
So, at a young age I've
been shot when I was what?
15. I got shot in the arm and in the leg.
You know what I mean?
And I've been strong.
I mean, I'm just,
I just feel like I'm a strong individual.
You know what I mean?
I feel like my story should be heard
because I've been through a whole lot.
You know what I mean?
It's a lot of stuff
that I haven't named out
that I've been through.
But you know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] Do you
have kids of your own?
- I don't have any kids.
- [Interviewer] No kids.
- I don't have any kids
because I don't want to,
I don't want to bring no kids
off here in these streets.
And I watched these
girls struggle so hard.
You know what I mean?
They struggle hard. You know what I mean?
Then it's girls out here
that get their kids taken
because they trying to survive
out here in the streets.
They, you know what I mean?
Where they don't have no job.
They have to, okay.
They're out here prostituting.
So now they're getting they kid taken
by DCFS because they out
here trying to make a living
and stuff, not going right.
You know what I mean?
I watch all that shit go down.
I didn't, you know what I mean?
I done seen pimps drop the baby off.
If the girl don't want to be with them,
they done drop the baby
off at the police station.
It's just been, it's a
crazy world out here.
That's why I don't have any kids.
I don't want none right now.
Now if I was to settle down,
and I met the right guy and to get married
and even though it's late start,
I would want to do it.
You know what I mean?
But I don't want to bring my kid out here
to do what I'm doing right now.
No.
- [Interviewer] What would
you say to a young girl
who's considering doing
something like that.
- I would tell her, "Baby,
You don't, you don't need to like,"
Matter of fact,
it's a girl that I've met recently
and she's probably six months pregnant.
She's out here prostituting,
letting guys have sex with her.
- [Interviewer] I talked
to her yesterday. (laughs)
- Red hair?
- [Interviewer] Red hair.
- Mhm. It's a lot of,
it's a lot of, you know
and she doesn't respect it.
I told her having a baby is a,
is a very precious moment.
You don't want your baby out here.
You letting guys run
through you like a train.
You know what I mean?
Having a cigarette, you got
your baby in your stomach.
You're out here, prostituting.
You're out here trying to fight.
You don't need to do that.
Having a baby is a very beautiful thing,
but it's a very dangerous thing also
because they can also kill you.
If you have a miscarriage,
she can also kill you.
You know what I mean?
Or you having a baby out here
and you doing what I'm doing in the game,
or you have a pimp and
the pimp mad because
it's not their baby.
They might do something. You never know.
Where are you bringing your baby to?
You know what I mean?
You never know how a guy might feel.
"Oh it's not my baby. Oh I'm-"
You know what I mean?
"I'm a hurt this-"
or this bitch done did something wrong
now, I'm going to fuck this baby up.
Or you know me,
I'm gonna fuck this bitch
up and take her baby.
You never know, have another
bitch raise the baby.
It's just,
it's a lot of shit I've
seen out here that's crazy.
So, that's why I will
not have no kids out here
and I would tell the young girl,
"You out here don't get
pregnant, use protection, baby.
Cause it feels just the same."
- [Interviewer] Do you
get depressed sometimes?
- A lot.
A lot cause sometimes it'd be like
a struggle to be out here
doing what I'm doing.
Especially with no stability.
Like, I don't have stability right now.
I don't have an apartment.
I don't, you know what I mean?
Like I was just,
I was just sleeping.
I don't know the girl that
you interviewed before.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I was just sleeping at they house.
You know what I mean?
And they have, fleek galore.
You know what I'm saying?
I had to back up and like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, this is not me.
I need somewhere to go, but fuck it
I'm just going to start
back doing what I'm doing.
You know what I mean?
But I ended up meeting a nice guy
and I haven't prostituted or any of that,
you know what I mean?
He ain't pressuring me for sex or nothing.
He like me for me, but it's
like, I don't trust him.
I have very high trust issues.
So I'm not even giving him a chance.
You know what I mean?
And he don't, he ain't asked me,
"Oh you going outside?" Or,
all them girls up at that motel room
is hoeing and doing all that.
He hasn't did anything.
He grabbed me- bought me-
did everything for me.
I don't have any clothes right now.
He did everything for me,
but it's like, I don't trust them.
Cause I'm like, what is your motive?
You know what I mean? Like.
- [Interviewer] How much money
did you make in a tonight?
- Depends on what night it is.
Like, if it's like a,
I'm going to say it like a
Monday through Wednesday,
I'll probably make like,
probably like four, 400
or something like that.
If it's like a Thursday
through like Sunday thing,
I probably make like close to like 900.
It depends. It just depends.
Some days it'd be slow for me though.
I mean, since all this
stuff's been going on
I've been like really slow.
So, shit I could say,
like I haven't been outside lately but
when I was going outside,
probably I make like 175.
Re- like lately, like
you know what I mean?
And that's, if that.
- [Interviewer] Do you
remember your first time?
- I remember my first time.
My first time was with a, my-
turned out folks.
Which first time?
The first time me prostituting? Or?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Okay um,
My turn out folk, he set up a for me
before I even went out,
he set a date up for me
so I can feel comfortable
because I wasn't having sex.
All this shit happened,
all this shit happened after
me going, getting out of jail.
- [Interviewer] So your
first time having sex
was working as a prostitute?
- No.
- [Interviewer] No?
- I- with him first and then,
you know what I mean?
He got me comfortable with someone
of that, you know, a trick.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
And I- a trick gave me what, 300?
In my hand to make me feel
comfortable, you know?
And it was like, he told
me everything to do.
Always, never put a price in your life.
That's my turn out folks.
That's why I always respect him.
He always told me "I don't
care how much they got,
never do it to a John without a condom."
Never, because if they're paying,
if they're trying to pay you,
they're trying to pay you
to give you something.
You know what I mean?
Cause they don't know if you clean or not.
They don't know how many
times you done did this.
You know how many times,
you know what I mean?
How many guys you said
yes to, without a condom.
You know what I mean?
So if they tried to, do it
to you without a condom,
never put a price in your life.
That's- and I always stuck with that.
That's how, you know what I mean.
I'm safe now.
You know, I can take a HIV and AIDS test
and not worry about, "Oh, I'm scared.
Cause I know I've been out
here having unprotected sex."
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- A lot of girls out here doing it for,
for funds, for money.
But I mean, you can get
the same amount of money
when using protection because I have.
You know what I mean?
Even with conversations,
like even with conversations
I always been lucky, like to get,
get good money.
You know what I mean?
Cause good company is good money.
It ain't always about sex.
Some people will be
lonely and they be wanting
a little company, you know what I mean?
And they'll pay for that.
And if anything happens
extra, you know, it's happens.
But.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- Yeah I've been in love
before and I got hurt.
You know what I mean?
So now I'm scared.
I'm scared to love, you know what I mean?
Cause sometimes we think it's love.
It's really not love,
it's- you can, it's what you can do for
like in this game is
what you can do for a guy
because you could easily
lose his attention
and his love for the next girl.
She can give him more.
You know what I mean?
So you would think you in love and go,
"Oh I'm in love with this guy"
and he'll tell you, "Oh, I love you."
You know what I mean?
And that's just something
that these pimps say to girls.
They might love you,
but they love what you
can do for him more.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] And it must be hard
to have a real committed
relationship with,
with the career like this.
- Yeah. I be feeling like,
like I'll never find
nobody that's going to
love me for me because of my lifestyle.
I feel like that like,
even though I can be the prettiest girl,
he can be, you know what I mean?
I could be the prettiest girl
and like my lifestyle
determines everything.
You know what I mean?
My lifestyle determines everything.
I can, I can be dressed the best,
prettiest, got the best personality,
but because I prostitute,
I will never find nobody.
Like, you know what I mean?
That's going to love me for me.
The guy- even if it, it is a guy that do,
I don't trust it.
It's like my trust issues
are at an all time high.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
I don't give anybody a chance.
I want to maybe like to him, believe him
but they be like mm-mm.
My caution button go up and it's like, no,
you don't love me.
You love, what you heard
about what I can do
or, you know what I mean?
Like the guy now, like I only been talking
to him probably like a
week to almost two weeks
and he tells me he loves me,
but I don't believe him.
You know what I mean?
Cause you don't know me to love me,
you know what I mean?
You're doing it for me. Yeah.
But you probably got a motive.
Probably not, probably so.
You know what I mean?
I won't know until how long we ever,
how long we spent, you know what I mean?
If he gets, if he gets to know me right.
Or if he'd be like,
"Oh, she don't want to have sex with me."
So, cause we haven't had sex yet.
So it's like, she don't
want to do nothing with me.
And I've been spending all this money.
Oh I'm cool on her.
That'll show that's no love.
You know what I mean?
So I don't know.
I'll be feeling like,
I'll never find nobody
because my lifestyle.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
How do you think this
life has changed you?
- It changed me tremendously because
not only am I book
smart, I'm street smart,
you know what I mean?
And I'm a lot cautious
and I go off my first mind all money,
all money ain't good money to me.
If I felt- because I had a friend
me and her used to be in
competition a whole lot.
We used to be, we used
to be on the, on Fig.
We used to be on 84th and Fig.
We used to be competition a whole lot.
She was on a date.
I was on a date with-
you know what I'm saying?
We will do a date together.
And one day we just date together,
and then the guy wasn't feeling her.
So he told her, she,
he gave her some money.
He told her she can, she can leave.
(inaudible) Me and kicked
it for a little while.
When I come back outside,
she still outside.
So when I come back outside,
we were talking and stuff like that.
His car pulled up.
So when the car pulls up,
everybody's interviewed him.
I interviewed him.
She's the last person to interview him.
And we like, "uh-uh" we got a bad vibe.
We got a bad vibe.
You know what I mean?
Hell no, hell no.
And she like, "Oh yeah."
Cause Red, rest in peace,
Red the type of girl
she like, all money in.
You know what I mean, bitch please.
You know what I'm saying?
He got the money, I'm going.
You know what I mean?
I don't give a fuck what
y'all talking about.
So she's like, "Oh y'all missing money"
and jumped in the car.
Red never came back.
Red was found,
they found Red dead all
the way in, what is it?
Apple Valley?
And I'll never forget the car.
Cause it was a burgundy car.
And when you get up on a car,
you can tell if a guy-
you didn't have no good vibe about him.
And Red is resting in
peace right now because,
you know what I mean?
A lot of girls be in competition.
It's just like a lot of stuff.
Tragically happening out here.
I got a friend that, I
got a couple of girls
that I worked with
that's resting in peace.
Know what I'm saying?
Because we, we wanna,
we want to find love.
We want to get this money
for our pimp like so bad, like,
"Oh I'm gonna make, I'm
gonna make more than her.
So when he talks to my pimp,
he's gonna know that I made more,"
you know what I'm saying?
Like, and sometime we only,
we don't even think that-
thinking about our first vibe,
I always go with my vibe.
Like if I not vibing you, I'm not going.
You know what I mean?
If I even have a cringe
in my skin about you
and I broke, I'm gonna stay broke.
You know what I mean?
I'm not going to go.
I'm just not because I, because I,
I follow my first mind that night and Red,
I don't know if she had a bad vibe
or she just wanted to get more money.
Cause I stayed with the,
you know what I mean?
Now she gone, you know what I mean?
And she was a good friend
to a lot of people,
we've been in the game for a minute.
You know what I'm saying?
This game, I done seen
it change tremendously.
Like now, it was pimping and pandering.
It went from pimping and pandering,
to human trafficking
because a lot of girls
let me tell you,
a lot of girls they get arrested, right?
They're not- a lot of
girls want to be victims
and they get arrested right?
So instead of them telling the truth,
and be like, "Oh. I turned the guy out."
because a lot of girls,
we leave placement.
We leave all types of places.
And we like, we find a
boyfriend and be like,
"Oh I know how to get some money."
And you think a guy gonna say,
"Oh no, don't do that."
If I be like, "Oh, I can
make $500 right now, baby.
Let me show you how."
You don't think he gonna be like,
and then I'm gonna have another friend.
She can be like, "Oh I can do it too."
You know what I'm saying?
And that's how it all start.
It'd be pimps out here that's orphans too.
They didn't, people don't
want to hear their story
because it's like, they're,
they're known as the bad guys.
You know what I mean?
Like pimps are known as the bad guy
but you got a lot of-
you got different pimps.
You got gorillas,
you got finesse, which is finesse-
Gorillas are the ones that,
"Oh bitch you got to get
outside and get my money.
Bitch I don't give a fuck about,
go to hell or go to jail bitch.
I don't give a fuck if it's
15 police outside bitch,
work around them."
You know what I'm saying?
That's the gorilla.
That's what I was dealing with
when I first got in the game,
and I didn't know, you know what I mean?
And I got, he did this to me and all that
because I was so crazy about him.
Cause he had the long hair,
and the light skin and he was just fine.
You know what I'm saying?
And then you got a finesse.
I done mess with a finesse pimp before
where he don't even, feel
like he got to touch you.
If he got to touch you- you can go.
You know what I'm saying?
He was like, "I got so many bitches on me.
Bitch I got so many
bitches paying me bitch.
I don't even give a
fuck about none of that,
since you talking about, you can go,"
you know what I'm saying?
Then you got the ones that's like
boyfriend and girlfriend pimps.
You know what I'm saying?
He only want one bitch.
He only want one girl.
And y'all just getting your
money together like that.
You got so much,
so many different types of people out here
that when they hear pimp, they be like,
"Aw that motherfuckers mean,
that motherfuckers not cool."
You know what I'm saying?
Because pimp.
No, it's a lot of people
that's in jail right now
that girls lied on because you got a girl-
you got- say there's five of us right?
We all in competition
because it's five of us.
And we got that one dude
and everybody's craving for attention.
He liked this about one girl.
He liked this is about another girl.
He like, you know what I'm saying?
It's- and we allowed
him to pimp on us like
oh we in competition with each other.
So you'll have- he
really liked one though.
You know what I'm saying?
It always be like that.
He'll really like one so
that's his bottom bitch.
You know what I'm saying?
Bottom bitches always,
really a girlfriend.
You know what I'm saying?
So you'll have one, that's
like a bottom bitch.
You know what I'm saying?
And then we in competition with her.
So now he like, "Oh, this is my bitch."
So now another girl gonna be like,
"Oh, I'm telling on him.
I'm telling the police."
So the police be like,
"Oh tell us your pimp name and all that."
She already mad at him
so she like "Fuck that."
You know what I'm saying?
He ain't forced her outside.
And then, you know,
you notice a lot of girls with
guys names tatted on them.
You know what I'm saying?
I know you done seen
a lot of girls with guys
names tatted on them.
And then they'd be like, "Oh,
oh, he forced me to do this."
But then the words so neat.
People don't- it's a lot of
human trafficking out here
that, that's not even,
that's not even known.
Like you have a different race,
human trafficking they own race.
But you, they so into our game right now,
the pimp and the hoe game,
and they think everybody can,
they want to change the human trafficking
or slavery or all that.
We can get away if we want to,
you know what I'm saying?
We can- why do you think
the girls choose up to different pimps?
"Oh, I'm gonna go with him.
I'm gonna go with him.
I'm gonna go with him."
So if that was the case,
why a lot of girl not dead right now?
You know what I mean?
It's just like a funny game to me
because this is something that,
that they want to believe.
Like not saying that pimping,
cause I don't believe, I'm not gonna lie.
I believe every girl
should get they own money.
Like, because I matched with the game.
I know. Ain't nobody gonna tell me,
"Oh no you can't go get your nails did."
After I done gave him $500.
You know what I'm saying?
Or "No, bitch you ain't getting
no outfit today. Tomorrow."
Oh no. You know what I'm saying?
When you can go and make your own money.
Cause right now ain't nothing going on.
But BFP's and that's the boyfriend pants.
You know what I'm saying?
And some guy that still think
they could have a lot of girls,
but everybody running them up,
because the game is so different.
And us human trafficking,
people are scared.
You know what I mean?
And, but that just brought me to say
like a lot of guys be
orphans too, you know?
So you think they,
a lot of guys be homeless too.
You think of a girl,
pretty as girl walked up,
she's like,
"Oh, I know I could make us some money."
How you- like if it was you,
what would you do?
Like if a girl,
if you were homeless and the girl be like
"I know I can make us some money."
You're going to tell
her "No, don't do that."
And she still gonna do it.
You know what I mean?
With you or somebody else.
This game is a dog eat dog world.
And if I could,
some girls like "Shit,
better him than me."
You know what I mean?
But they don't know that this guy
facing the rest of his life
and then I'm facing,
I'm facing six months for a prostitute.
And they facing the rest of their life
because they, they got so many
trumped up charges and they ain't did shit
but be nice to the girl the whole time.
- [Interviewer] So what you're saying,
rather than blaming the pimp
for the entire situation,
sometimes it's the female who-
- Cause we not- we not other girls like
- [Interviewer] It takes two to tango.
- And we not other girls like, we be like,
Oh, come home to my-"
You know what I said?
That's our job. That's the job..
That just, especially
when you a bottom bitch.
- [Interviewer] I've seen,
I've been photographing, interviewing,
a lot of pimps and prostitutes.
And I've seen the interaction
outside on the street.
A girl was sitting here with me
saying all this negative
stuff about pimps.
"I don't need that shit.
I don't, I'm not going to
give somebody my money."
And as soon as she steps outside,
and sees that well-dressed cool, dude,
she gets weak in the knees
and she's standing really close to him
and looking him, looking up at him and-
- But see, you got me-
- [Interviewer] Falling in love with him.
- Everybody know me, I'm Rene-
They call me Renegade Spice.
You know what I'm saying?
I've been around for a cool minute.
I done had my shares of
pimps when I was younger.
You know what I mean?
I have very high trust issues,
I don't give a fuck if
a motherfucker put up,
in his motherfucking $3 million suit,
bitch you ain't getting me.
I don't give a fuck,
because you for the game.
You know what I mean?
I done been through it.
Been there, done that.
You know what I mean?
Now I got me a guy, and we do it together.
I done did that a couple of times.
You know what I mean?
And they don't know if
they want me to be a hoe
or they want me to be their girlfriend.
You know what I'm saying?
So they get jealous at times,
because they don't
understand my lifestyle.
So like I said, that's why I feel like
I'll never really find love because
soon as I get broke,
I'll be like, " Shit,
I need some fast cash."
You feel me?
Fuck what he talking about
he ain't got no money for me.
You feel me?
And it's like, owned to this game,
you know what I mean?
Sometimes it be like,
"Oh, I want to find love."
But then I'm like,
"That motherfucker never understand me."
And they won't, you know what I'm saying?
Because you got they family
members probably judgmental.
You got, people that's-
they seeing you on Long
Beach Boulevard or Figueroa.
You know what I mean?
That know you a hoe. They-
people don't want to bring
that shit to they families.
You know what I'm saying?
Because they feel like,
you know what I mean?
Like my family,
they don't really do
nothing to, nothing for me.
You know what I mean?
Because the life I chose to live,
I didn't, I wasn't raised like this.
Oh yeah.
We're going to all be hoes.
I wasn't raised like that.
No, I was raised in church
and everything else.
So I know my grandmother
turning over in her grave site
watching me do this.
You know what I mean?
But it's something, it's fast cash.
I don't know if I could
ever get a job and be like
you know what I'm saying?
My story is a tragic story.
You know what I'm saying?
But, people can't make it seem
like the game been all bad
because it has it's goods in it too.
You know what I mean?
I done have fun times
and I done had bad times.
And that's with any life story,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, but,
would I wish this on anybody?
No.
Cause it's, it's addicting.
You know what I mean?
You'll get out the game for a minute,
like, "Fuck, I ain't
doing that shit no more."
I don't know how many
time I done been to jail
like "Oh, I'm gonna change my life.
I swear to God. God, listen to me.
Please like, if you let me out today,
I promise you, I ain't
going to do this no more."
As soon as I get out,
I'm back to the game.
You feel me?
Forgot I done said that,
you know what I mean?
So, and a lot of us do that.
Know what I'm saying?
I don't know how many I done did that
or called my family like,
"Fam let me come home.
I'm gonna just change my whole life."
Soon as I get home, I'm back to-
you feel me?
Cause this game is addicting.
You know what I mean?
I like to smoke a lot of weed.
Yeah I smoke Kush.
You feel me?
So that being said, like my shit,
I got up and I don't like
to just buy no $10 bag
or none of that shit.
So I be wanting to spend my,
whatever I want to spend on.
I got to the point where I spoil myself.
So, if I make some money I be
wanting to spend my own money
like I'll be wanting to buy this,
buy that, buy this, buy that.
And I feel like with a
job, you got to wait.
No, I can't wait for no check.
I be, I like fast cash.
And that's just with any girl
that's been in my lifestyle.
It's hard for them to adjust to,
to try to have a job.
They be like, "Oh, you can get a job."
I can. But will I? No.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, you know what I mean?
I can probably, you know what I'm saying?
But it's hard.
Like, especially everyday
you have like a lot of money in your hand.
Like from one night, you know what I mean?
You get like 700, 800.
You like shit, fuck all that.
I ain't fucking waiting for no check.
- [Interviewer] Great.
Are you saving money?
- Hm?
- [Interviewer] Are you saving money?
- I'm not gonna lie.
Every day is a struggle for me.
Cause you, it be some
days I don't go outside.
Cause I, I done made 700.
So I be like, I ain't going outside today,
I'm just gonna pay my rent like this,
I'm gonna pay with this.
I'm gonna pay with this you feel me?
Buy me some weed, have
weed for like two days.
You know what I'm saying?
No, I don't save money.
And, and I'm not gonna lie.
Like every day is a struggle for me.
Cause I don't know if I'm
going to have some money or not
because I want to buy these.
I want to buy clothes.
I want to buy this.
You know what I'm saying?
And then I ain't been working.
Cause I caught a couple
of cases also recently.
So I ain't been working but,
it's a constant struggle for me every day.
And I do it by myself.
Like I'm by myself like, out here.
Cause my family, they not really
messing with me right now
because of the choices I made.
You know what I'm saying?
It's not their fault.
It's my fault.
You know what I mean? So.
- [Interviewer] Does
your, your family knows?
- They don't like it. So no.
They tried to help me, when they can
but I don't reach out
either because I'll be like
"I'm out here by my, I'm
out here doing it myself."
Like, because it's always,
they have something to say
you know what I'm saying?
Instead of just trying to help me,
they always have,
everybody always have an opinion.
My mother's passed away.
So I don't have a mother anymore.
My father, he doesn't
really do too much for me
but it's the choices I've made.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] All right, Tasha,
thank you so much for sharing your story.
Thank you.